(Clapping) "Five, six, seven, eight."
(Music)
Student 1: I am a junior here at Princeton
in the art history department.
Student 2: I’m a molecular biology major.
Student 3: I’m a senior
in the anthropology department.
Student 4: I’m studying psychology with certificates
in theater and dance.
Student 5: I’m thinking of majoring
in molecular biology.
Student 6: I’m interested in chemistry
and neuroscience.
Student 7: I’m studying electrical engineering.
Stuart Singer: My name is Stuart Singer.
I am here at Princeton
re-staging Bill T. Jones and Arnie Zane's
"Continuous Replay."
... Essentially what begins as a very dry,
formal set of still images
becomes a much wilder moving picture.
Student 8: It's an emotional, physical, mental,
full-body commitment.
Student 1: There's a section of 48 movements
and a section of 22 ...
Student 8: I’m mostly trained in classical ballet
so Stuart will have to remind me
to relax my pointed feet.
Student 1: You have to go all out and, like, hiss.
(Hissing)
Stuart Singer: We're in a room with some
very intelligent young minds,
some very ambitious young minds.
This challenges them in a way, in that
there's no easy right answer.
The right answer is to be you.
Brian Reeder: I’m Brian Reeder, I'm an
independent freelance choreographer.
Student 3: We have this idea that ballet is
a bunch of people dancing around
in little pink tutus, and it is
very far from that.
Brian Reeder: You can take this balletic sensibility
and stretch it out, and twerk it, and twist it
and go in different directions.
I have a couple dancers up en pointe,
not the entire cast.
I like to merge the two together: the
sock dance, the barefoot, and pointe work.
Jimena Paz: My name is Jimena Paz, I'm actually
teaching a dance that I learned
when I was the students' age.
I'm thinking of the dancers as
who they are, and
thinking of their bodies as content
rather than as instruments.
I asked the dancers to think of
some words that define them.
Student 9: Mine was glass bottle.
Jimena Paz: I call them "anchors," they
anchor the movement.
Student 4: Every day the dance changes,
but it changes on you, in your body.
It's the fact that we're allowed
to make mistakes,
and sometimes mistakes
end up being in the number!
Jimena Paz: They're tired, but they're wonderful.
I actually thought all of them
were art majors, which they are not.
Dean Moss: My name is Dean Moss.
I am putting a piece that's already made
on them, with some caveats.
Student 7: He brought in one of the boards.
Dean Moss: So the boards look like this.
Student 7: It's quite large, so it takes some
getting used to.
Student 5: The board keeps slipping out of my hands,
I can't get it to transfer ...
Student 7: How to hold it, how to move it without it
hitting into yourself,
And then you switch your hands,
I think --- wait ...
Dean Moss: Working with the Princeton students,
they're smart, they're enthusiastic,
they have a kind of brilliance about them.
Vicky Shick: I’m Vicky Shick
Eva Karczag: And I’m Eva Karczag
from the Trisha Brown Company,
and we were both in the original cast
of "Set and Reset."
Vicky Shick: They're not just learning material, but
they're actually learning a process.
Student 10: The movement is definitely not
virtuosic, as you might think of it,
but it's very specific and requires
so much precision.
Loni Landon: My name is Loni Landon and I'm creating
a piece for the Princeton Dance Festival.
Each week I've given them a different task
with movement, or a phrase of movement I've taught them.
It's really inspiring to me and
motivating, so I want to challenge them
to go further, physically.
Student 2: You'll discover and move in new ways
that you didn't know possible.
Student 11: It's more about organic movement
and isolating different body parts.
Student 2: So where something is usually really
physical, it kind of became gestural.
Dancers: That's All!
Stuart Singer: Not bad, not bad.